the Alam meme that we consider that as a
miracle, right? Our community has agreed
upon that. It's not unclear, it's just a
miracle.
Well, no, no, your community does agree
that it's unclear. Your community, as
you as you affirmed, says that we don't
know what this means. It's a miracle, so
we don't even bother to draw.
That means it's unclear.
It's unclear.
But they came to a conclusion. It's a
miracle.
So, it it being a miracle doesn't change
the fact that it's unclear, right?
No, it it just it's a miracle.
Yeah. Wait, it's a it's a miracle that's
unclear.
Yes. So, you can't just put miracle in
front of something that's illogical,
right? So, let's say you try to bring up
like a logical contradiction in the
Trinity or in the Bible or in our faith.
We can't just say, "Oh, it's a miracle,
so therefore it's solved." That's not
how miracles work, right? Otherwise,
anyone could use that principle to solve
any argument and then no one can really
argue with anyone.
Welcome to the podcast, man. How you
doing, bro?
We're blessed. We're blessed by the
Lord. Tell us, man. Uh, were you born a
Muslim? Yeah.
Okay. You were born into mus into Islam
and you're
I'm sorry to cut you off. What's the
topic of this? Like because I I I can
usually tell by the YouTube videos name,
but like this time it just said join.
Yeah. Well, I was I was just about to
bring one up.
All right. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Yeah. So, really, I want to just start
off by asking you what give me like one
thing that convinces you that Islam is
is true. What what what is it that for
you is this is the biggest truth for
Islam that convinces you to stay in it
and choose it
from like other religions or just leave
other religions out?
Just just you in particular? Yeah. You
you in light of Islam, why why Islam is
the actual truth? Cuz let's say other
religions are false. That doesn't
necessarily mean Islam is how do you
know Islam is true?
Okay. So I believe I know you don't
believe this. I believe our book is
perfect.
Okay. And the main reason is like I
believe for God to be perfect. So if if
God's perfect, he would not send a
manual down without any doubt like
having any doubt in it or any mistakes
in it. That's just one. But like
in the Quran
are strong, you know.
That is a strong one.
So So really what you're saying is is
that Well, it sounds like he's saying
that the you know the Quran is like it's
it's so pure that it has no doubts.
Are you saying no mistakes or doubts?
cuz I heard doubts.
You can say both.
Okay. Okay.
And then I have one more reason.
Okay. We we'll get to the the second
reason. So we'll do it one at a time.
Okay. So does anybody want to comment on
that? He says that the Quran, you know,
it's it's it's true because, you know,
as as far as it's pure pure, free of
mistakes.
I I think one problem with this is, and
we've all talked about this before,
this seems to be an affirming the
consequent fallacy. And I've said this
on Logic's live stream as well, right?
So it's almost like saying the Quran is
like free of contradictions. The Quran
is like this or that. So it's like
saying if the Quran is free of
contradiction then the Quran is true.
The Quran is free of contradiction
therefore the Quran is true. So this is
logically facious. It's like saying if P
therefore Q
therefore P. But this isn't how logic
works. It's like saying
if the room is dark the light is broken.
Oh, sorry. If the light is broken, the
room is dark. The room is dark,
therefore the light is broken. But
obviously that doesn't necessarily
follow from that. So I don't think that
that would be a good proof to show you
that Islam is necessarily true.
Um the Quran makes this argument surah 4
ayah 82. If this book is from other than
Allah and you will find many
contradictions in it consequent. How do
you prove that it is from Allah? The you
prove be the consequent that it has no
contradiction. But that doesn't follow.
So that's a big mistake in the Quran
right there. You go there. God doesn't
know logic.
All right. All right. So,
God makes a fallacy himself according to
that which God couldn't do.
Okay. So, let's just make it simple so
that he can actually have something to
respond to. So,
he's saying that there's no mistakes in
the Quran. Therefore, it's true, right?
That's one of the reasons why he
believes in it and and you know there's
no reason to doubt it.
You guys are saying that actually within
the Quran Allah commits a logical
fallacy with a challenge that he
presents.
Okay. And so with him saying that, you
know, um if this book has no uh no
contradictions or inconsistencies, then
it's not from Allah. You're saying that
that's a problem.
Yeah. Precisely. Because
Yeah. Because
ultimately, right, the way that the
fallacy works is that if you have this,
this is supposed to be the consequence.
Okay.
The problem with that way of thinking is
this is this is fine. If I say if I'm in
the castle, then I'm in the city. That
makes so much sense. that's fine. But
just because I'm in the city, it doesn't
mean I'm in the castle.
It doesn't follow at all. So when the
Quran makes the point that if this is
other than Allah, then there will be a
contradiction.
That's fine. If it's from God, there
shouldn't be a contradiction. That's
fine on its own.
It's when they say that because there's
no contradiction, therefore the Quran is
from God.
Exactly.
You're taking the consequence, the thing
that's supposed to come about
to prove its cause.
That's the problem. So, so what what do
you think about what they just said?
Mama, go ahead and respond. I want to
hear your thoughts.
Um, so he said you can't just go off of
like if there's not a contradiction that
means it's true, right?
Right.
Basically, yeah.
Yeah. Doesn't follow.
But that's just one way of it. And then
then what was the other thing you said?
The last guy to speak.
Um, I'm saying okay, Muhammad, can I
talk to you if that's okay?
Okay. So you said that one of the
reasons why you believe that Islam is
true is because the Quran does not
contain any contradictions or
inconsistencies. Is this correct?
Yeah. Just one of them. Yeah.
Okay. My point is that this very
argument that the Quran makes is
illogical.
It's a flaw in reasoning.
Why?
Because you can't use just the fact that
there's no contradictions in it to make
it that it's true. Case in point, if
someone hand this pack of sweets. Okay.
Okay. See this, right? This pack of
sweets doesn't have any contradiction on
it. Okay. Does this mean that it's from
God? This pack of sweets?
No, it doesn't.
Question. Does it mean it's from God?
Yeah. This pack of sweets has no
contradiction. It's nerds by it's
rainbow candy.
Does this mean that it's from God?
It is from God.
This is not like divine inspiration.
Obviously, God is obviously God made it.
But you understand what I mean when I
say that this is from God. Is this like
divine revelation from God?
Oh, no. No. No.
Okay.
Exactly.
So, just because something doesn't have
a contradiction doesn't mean it's divine
inspiration. Okay.
Yeah. That was just one way. But it
could be for sure it could be if you
compare
I don't I don't think anyone thinks this
has
No, I'm not talking about nerds. I'm not
talking about nerds. I'm talking about
like
Yeah. But the thing is right when it
comes to the claim that
it's just one criteria, that's all.
We're saying it's not a criteria at all.
It fails to it fails. It's insufficient.
Completely insufficient.
Why?
Because it doesn't show you anything. It
doesn't prove it. Well, well, if
anything, it's a positive proof against
the Quran, right? Because if God is
making an argument for his scripture
from the Quran, yet he makes a logical
fallacy in that argumentation, and we
know that God cannot make logical
fallacies because God is not an
illogical being, then that would mean
that the Quran is false. If it makes a
logical fallacy, but the argument put
forth here is a logical fallacy. So,
what you've just said in fact falsifies
the Quran.
Indeed.
No. Look, it was just a point I was
making like for a book to be the truth,
it had can't have no mistakes in it.
That's all that was just one point of
Yeah. Okay. So,
but that's okay. Even then, right? Let's
say that's you want to go.
Yeah. Yeah. So, with that, we agree like
we said the statement, the light is
broken, therefore the room is dark is
fine because that's true. The same
statement, if this is from Allah, you
will have no contradiction. That's fine.
But the problem is that Allah's making a
claim. He's making an argument. So, then
what follows is how do you prove that
it's from Allah? According to Allah, you
prove there's no contradictions. Now in
that argument the same way then if I say
with the first example the light is the
light is broken therefore the room is
dark. The room being dark doesn't then
mean the light is broken. In the same
regard
when you say there is no contradiction
it doesn't prove that it's from Allah
and this is why Allah's own argument is
actually fellacious. You can go on your
phone right now look up affirming the
consequence. You'll discover it's a
logical fallacy formally and you you'll
come to understand. I might draw.
Yeah. Just draw the fall.
I can't. So you're saying nobody could
use that point of criteria to prove
their book is the truth
because the problem is is look it's the
problem is is effect of it. It's not a
proof of it.
For example, right? If I have a son, my
son will be Nigerian. Just because
there's a Nigerian baby, that doesn't
mean it's not my son. That kid is not my
son. Okay? Now, the point that Anando
when he finishes with the whiteboard is
going to show you is that if A is true,
B is also true.
Just because you have B doesn't mean
that A is true.
Exactly.
So, what we're trying to ask you is is,
hey, if the Quran is from God, then
there should be no contradictions.
That's cool. If we ask you to prove how
the Quran is true, you can't appeal to
its lack of contradiction. That's just
an effect of the Quran apparently. Show
the whiteboard.
Yeah. Show the whiteboard. Right.
So when we go from A, that's the
anticedant of B. That's the consequence.
Okay. We we can affirm this. We can say
like I said, if A the light is broken,
then it does follow B. The room is dark.
But if we do B to A,
exactly,
the room is dark, therefore the light is
broken. Well, that's not a necessary
inference. It doesn't have to follow
will be the case if the light could be
turned off. I could have took the light
bulb out. Could have no power in the
house.
Any other any other inferences or
intellments could be there.
In the same regard, a book without no
contradictions. Phone books have no
contradictions. My notes have no
contradictions, Lord willing.
Exactly.
So, you know, these things don't matter.
And you might appeal to the fact that
humans make mistakes, but that's going
to be a universal claim. And in
particular instances, humans can make
works without errors. Yeah.
So, it's very important to know that
when Allah says a If there's from other
than Allah, that's the answer to them.
B, you'll find no contradictions in it.
And that's if you had a book from God,
you should expect no contradictions in
it. The problem is it's a claim that's
meant to prove something.
The claim B is supposed to prove
something. So they use B to get A.
And that's where the fall comes in
because it does not follow.
And so this is a major flaw of the Quran
and we even just one just one that's a
challenge just one that's all. So yeah,
that's my explanation for you. So
I think we agree to disagree. But can
they're gonna ask you something on
disagree.
Wait, but you actually have to interact
with what he says rather than just ask
like no I'm gonna knock. What do you
think I'm going to say to this? Like I'm
not like this is logic,
right?
Like show that.
Yeah. So So again, the point is like for
example, you as as we've already said,
lack of having a contradiction is a
portion of what we would h what we would
expect to see if it's from God. But
simply not having a contradiction in
something which again we would protest.
It's not it's not prove that it's from
God.
Yeah.
It's not a reason to prove that it's
from God. Again, as we've said, a phone
book doesn't have anything like that.
And you could you could literally burn a
book and that book doesn't have any
contradictions because it's ashes. That
doesn't mean that it's divinely
inspired.
And the thing is when you want to say
bring the camera, bring the Muhammad
Muhammad. Yeah. Muhammad. Muhammad. Let
me just make something clear. this thing
that we're telling you. Yeah. It's a
fallacy of logic. Do you get it?
You have to understand.
You have to understand that this is an
agree to disagree point.
It's either true or it's not.
Like,
okay.
Would you agree that your God is a
logical God? He's not illogical.
Oh, you asking a question?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Logical definitely.
Yeah. So then when we find a logical
fallacy in his work, alleged work, we
shouldn't shouldn't we ask the question
why? We can't just throw away logic
because if we throw away logic, do you
know what? You become unreasonable. And
you know what? No one has the reason to
do believe in your worldview. If I just
say to you, believe in the trinity. Why?
Because you know I said so. That doesn't
really get us anywhere, does it? There's
no reason for you to ought to believe
me. And if you explain the trinity and I
say I can't, but Allah I can't explain
it but you just believe it. You're not
going to say why should I believe
something you can't explain.
The same regard if you don't want to
engage your logic then you're just
refusing to give any reason why anyone
even yourself ought to believe in your
worldview. You have no reason right now
to believe in this a claim which can be
my if my book had a contradiction in it
right you agreed to say yeah it's false
yeah I'm saying that the actual logical
form of the argument proves the Quran
false you know even at that
no no let's just say let's say we open
up the Quran right now and I could agree
let's just say you bring up something
and I'll be like yeah you're right
there's a mistake in there does that
make it false on your end
yeah logical fallacy can go God is the
grounding and cause of all logic if we
if God makes logical fallacies it's just
not real by God Yeah.
So like if there was a contradiction in
the Quran, that's you could like that's
that means the religion is false, right?
Sure. But even if they didn't have a
contradiction, would it make it from
God? That's the point.
Point though, that's one point. It
that's not okay. Essentially, it's not
even a point because anyone can do it.
You need to show me something only God
can do.
Yeah. It is it is by definition a
nonsequitary.
But let's let's do it this way. if if
this is a if this is a you know a
qualifier for him. Sure. Let's let's go
with his argument. Let's go with it.
Let's go with it. We've cussed it.
Yeah. So, you you guys did a an amazing
job on showing how even that it's not
even just bringing up a verse, but the
the challenge itself contains a logical
fallacy would be would be a problem. You
guys did a good job. But so now let's
but let's go now with him. his thing is
you know no like if there was a
contradiction then the book would not be
from God that's that's your position
right Muhammad
okay so this I I I do have a problem I
think that there's some people that
could bring up things that are not as
that you know could be vague you know
it's not clear but I believe that I have
I've seen a contradiction a few of them
one of them I mean there's no way out of
this is clear as day
when it comes to you know the Quran
saying now this is what I do I I when I
read the Quran I look at what it says on
a particular topic, multiple verses. I
see what it says in totality cuz you
know some verses can interpret others
and we can get the whole picture.
This there's no way out.
You know what I'm saying? So if you have
like Do you mind if I show you?
You go. Yeah, sure.
Okay. You know I like to see nice.
That's
all right. So I'm I'mma put I'mma put a
verse on the screen. I'mma put a verse
on the screen and I'm going to just show
you I'm going to show you a few verses
that say the same thing. Okay. just a
few so that you can get the idea because
I want to make sure that we're not
misrepresenting what the Quran. So, uh,
if we go to chapter 6, verse 114 of the
Quran, and this is what it says here.
Let me share my screen, man. What we
doing? Make sure you guys are hitting
the like button. By the way, if you guys
forgot to do that, you guys know what
you're doing behind the closed doors.
So, don't don't out yourselves. All
right? Do not out yourself. Hit that
like, share the live, all of that.
Come on, man.
Come on, man. Come on now, dog.
All right, here we go.
Just gonna read, man.
We're just gonna read. So, this is
chapter 6, verse 114. Can you see it on
the screen? I'm going to make sure.
Yeah, I can see.
All right, perfect. So, this says, all
right, shall I seek a judge other than a
law, while it is he who has sent down
unto you the book explained in detail?
Now, that's what we're going to be
paying attention to.
The book explained in detail. All right,
we're going to read the whole verse,
though, just to give it justice. Those
unto whom we gave the scripture know
that it is revealed from your Lord in
truth. So be not of those who doubt. So
pretty clear verse, right? It speaks for
itself. The Quran is explained in
detail, right? Uh and people know that
it's from the from the Lord. Allah is
the one who sent it down. Understood it
so far?
Yeah. Let me just read the second
sentence real quick.
Sure. Let me see. Right.
Those those unto whom we gave the
scripture Yeah.
know that it is revealed from your Lord
in truth. So be not of those who doubt.
All right.
All right. So the Quran is explained in
detail. We understand that, right?
Yeah.
All right. So we're gonna I'm gonna show
you one more verse that says the same
thing. One more verse that says the same
thing. This is chapter 12 verse 111.
Very last verse of the chapter. Chapter
12 verse 111. All right. So this what it
says here. Indeed in their stories there
is a lesson for men of understanding. It
the Quran is not a forged statement but
a confirmation of Allah's existing books
and and a detailed explanation of
everything and a guide and a mercy for
the people who believe.
Same thing, right?
Yep. Same thing. Now, this one says it's
detailed about everything, right? So,
it's going to go in details. There's no
it's not it explains it, right? Boom.
Basically,
so this is now this is what the problem
is. We see the Quran is consistent. I
can show you a few more other verses,
but it's pretty consistent. The Quran is
explained in detail. Boom. All right.
Now, let me show you the verse that
brings a problem with this. Okay. Go to
chapter 3:7. Here's the contradicting
verse. Chapter 3, verse number seven.
All right. Sure. We're zoomed in here.
But right now, you're trying to show me
like if there's a mistake now, right?
Yes. Yes. Now, I'm showing you the the
contradiction. The mistake here. All
right. So, it says, "It is he who has
sent down to you the book. In it are
verses that are entirely clear. They are
the foundations of the book. All right?
So there are verses that are entirely
clear. Those are the foundations of the
book. And others not entirely clear. So
there are some that are entirely clear.
There are others that are not entirely
clear
books.
No, about the Quran itself.
Okay.
So it's talking about the Quran itself.
So in it, right? So when we begin right
here, right in it. So in the Quran in it
are verses that are that are entirely
clear right and those are the
foundations of the book. Okay. Then it
says and others so other verses that are
not entirely clear. So as for those who
who whose uh hearts there are there is
deviation they they uh follow that which
is not entirely clear thereof. So the
ones who are deviant in heart use the
unclear verses to to try to follow after
seeking uh you know just believe it out
seeking for its hidden meanings. But
here it is but none knows its hidden
meanings save Allah. So only Allah knows
the meaning of these unclear verses.
Okay. They're not detailed.
Yeah.
And those who are firmly grounded in
knowledge they say we believe in it. The
whole of it all the whole of it is from
our Lord. So they don't even know it.
They just affirm that it's from God.
They don't know it. Only God knows these
meanings and none receive admonition
except men of understanding. All right.
So this verse says that there are some
clear verses while there are verses that
are unclear. While we saw two verses in
the Quran that said that the Quran is
detailed and explained and is a detailed
explanation about everything,
right?
What would you say is um what's your
definition of unclear? Or you could show
me example. Well, so if the Quran
doesn't go if the Quran mentions
something and it doesn't go into detail
about what it's talking about, then it's
not fully detailed. Like, so for
example,
there there's a Well, we got a few of
them, right? We got a few of them.
That's the problem here. Even even if we
don't go to our sources, we could just
go to quran.com and quran.com actually
explains the verses in the way that we
would interpret them. That's what was
meant to do that.
Yeah, I know. It's crazy. Literally,
there's a footnote on this verse on
quran.com and it says, "The precise
verses are easy to understand and deal
mostly with matters of belief and
practice."
As for the elusive verses, their full
meaning is known only to Allah, such as
the meaning of letter combinations at
the beginning of some surf
and how Allah settles himself on the
throne. The Quran is not clear or
perfectly detailed on those.
Yeah. So, so we see here, so there's
there's certain things in the Quran
that, you know, it's pretty clear about,
right? It's pretty self-evident or, you
know, it's clear in the verse, but there
are other things uh that are in the
Quran that you don't get, you know, has
missing details in there. You know what
I'm saying? Like for example, you Oh,
no. If you want to say something, go
ahead, Muhammad.
The Alam meme that we consider that as a
miracle, right?
Okay.
We don't consider that as like Allah
left us left us without a meaning and
now we have to figure it out. We don't
even bother figuring it out.
Wait, so you don't bother figuring out
what the Quran means?
Cuz this
So is there content? Okay. Because is
there content in the Quran that you
can't access?
No. Content like what do you mean? Like
something like
when we do like philosophy of language,
right? A word is going to point out a
specific thing in reality.
A signifier.
Yeah. It's going to signify something,
right?
Yeah. So words clearly have meaning. So
you saying that in the Quran, God is
revealing some words which don't have
meaning. They just don't signify certain
things in reality.
Yeah.
Because how how could you let me even
simp hold on sorry guys to to keep it
simply cuz to to focus on the argument.
He's saying that that's a miracle. We
don't even bother to try to know what
that means.
But that's not the point.
Do can does the Quran tell you what that
means? Is it detailed about for example?
I don't think so.
Right. So that's that would be an
example of an unclear verse. A part of
the Quran that's not detailed. Right.
Which which mean keep going. Keep going.
Yeah. So that would that would mean that
the Quran is not detailed and explained.
It's not a detailed explanation of
everything.
Right. That's a contradiction by the
way.
Yeah. A contradiction.
I wouldn't agree with that cuz majority
of scholars have agreed upon that like
it's a miracle and we'll only find out
when we die. But it's not like a
can I that's fine.
That doesn't change that doesn't that
doesn't change the fact that it's it's a
contradiction.
Of course it's not a contradiction cuz a
contradiction would be this meme and
they explain it. Let's just say in the
first first sentence it be like oh it
means God is the greatest. Let's just
say that right?
Okay.
And then you go down three chapters
later and Aliflam comes up and it says
no one will ever know what Aliflam means
when they die. That's a contradiction
now because you just told me what it
meant and now you're going to say it
means something.
Okay. So let so let me ask you this. Can
the can the Quran have unclear verses
while at the same time be a detailed
explanation of everything?
But I don't see that as unclear. You see
see what I'm trying to say? If it was
unclear then you're right 100%. But we
our community has agreed upon that it's
not unclear. It's just a miracle.
Well no no your community does agree
that it's unclear. Your community as you
as you affirmed says that we don't know
what this means. It's a miracle. So we
don't even bother to drive. means it's
unclear.
It's unclear.
But they came to a conclusion it's a
miracle
and you don't know.
So it it being a miracle doesn't change
the fact that it's unclear, right?
No, it it just it's a miracle.
It's a it's a miracle that's unclear.
You can't you can't just say
I don't think it's unclear. Unclear
would be like if you gave me a meaning.
Wait, go ahead. What were you saying?
Yeah. So you can't just put miracle in
front of something that's illogical,
right? So let's say you tried to bring
up like a logical contradiction in the
Trinity or in the Bible or in our faith.
We can't just say, "Oh, it's a miracle,
so therefore it's solved." That's not
how miracles work, right? Otherwise,
anyone could use that principle to solve
any argument and then no one can really
argue with anyone.
Heck, every Christian right now would do
it. I would do it right now.
Why not be a Hindu at that point and
just say, "How how are there 99,000
gods?" It's a miracle.
You know what I'm going to do? I'm going
to make this easy for you. Can Can you
see that? Okay,
you can read. Yeah, I see. I see
everything. So this is this is basic. I
I tried to make sure I didn't put any
notation. This is what God logic is
saying to you. The Quran is a detailed
explanation of everything. So everything
in the Quran is detailed. Everything in
the Quran is detailed. Then you have
something in the Quran that isn't
detailed. You're not supposed to have
that. So if you have everything being
detailed, but then you have something
which is part of everything that isn't
detailed, you have a problem because
you're supposed to have everything
detailed according to the verse.
Hey yo,
that was not meant by me. I I didn't I
didn't I didn't I didn't mean to do
that. I don't know how to sound here.
Okay.
Head shot.
But you get the point though. You
understand the point, right?
I understand what you're trying to say.
Yeah, I understand 100%.
So just because it's a miracle is
irrelevant. It's a miracle that's
unclear.
Yeah.
You understand? It's an unclear miracle
because you don't even know what the
miracle is.
That just makes it worse because now you
No, I agree. I agree. I don't know what
it is. Yeah, we we don't ponder on it.
We just know it's a miracle and we move
on.
Can you ponder on it? Right.
Right.
There's no point of pondering on it.
I know. Like, for example, there's no
point of me going to Skunp. I don't need
to go to Skunp. Right.
What's that?
Can I? Gunor is a random village in
England. I don't need to go there. Can
I? If I wanted to. Can I?
Cool. Great. And I can go to Texas as
well, but there's no point in me doing
it. Can you access this information? Can
you know it's clarity?
All we know it's a miracle.
How
can you know anything detailed about it?
Let me ask you how do you define a
miracle?
Oh, he already gave it up.
Yeah, he said that he he doesn't know
it.
So, if you don't know it, you can't know
it. Then it's unclear and and it's not
detailed, right? The Quran doesn't
detail that. However, the Quran says
elsewhere that it is a detailed
explanation of everything.
So, if there's something in the Quran
that's not detailed, then that means
there's a contradiction.
Exactly.
But, okay, I understand what you're
saying. Uh, you're not I'm listening to
you.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead. If you want
to respond, go ahead, please.
See, it also says like to go to the like
me, I'm a novice, right?
Yeah.
When it comes to like the scholars and
stuff. So
it also says go to the scholars when you
don't understand anything. Right?
Okay, hold on though. Hold on with that
point. The verse addresses that.
Remember if we read in verse in chapter
3 vers 7, the the verse we have the
problem with. I'll put it on the screen
again.
It says that not that no one knows the
meaning of these. No, none. Not even the
scholars. Look,
none except
Yeah, they don't. They don't. 100% they
don't. So then you can't go to the
scholars to to give it details,
but they agree upon something to clarify
it for the community. And if if they
didn't clarify anything and they didn't
say it's a miracle, oh man, we don't
know. It might mean this might mean
that, then you're 100% right,
mama. That doesn't clarify nothing.
Yeah.
It just they're just they're just in
consensus that this is unclear.
Yeah.
They they clarify that this is an
unclear verse. We won't know it. Only
Allah knows it.
Yeah. That's like imagine if like the
whole science community of the atheists
said, "Well, we don't know how the
universe was created. Would that mean
that God didn't create the universe?" Of
course not. I don't care. I'm going to
say this regularly. I don't care about
the consensus of individuals. If it
doesn't hurt my point,
my point is not on whether it's a
miracle or not. My point is on whether I
can understand it. And so long as
there's one thing, just one thing that
you don't understand, you have a
problem.
You understand that, right? I'm
listening to you.
Right. So, could you address that?
Yeah.
If you hold that up for just
I still honestly I still I'm definitely
going to go back to my people and try to
get a little more educated on it. So,
and hopefully I can join your chat
again.
So, if you look at that whiteboard
there, right, it says everything in Q.
So, let Q stand for Quran, right?
Everything in the Quran is C. Clear.
There is something in the Quran which is
not see clear. So it's like saying if I
was to say everyone in the room so let
room stand for Q there is 6 foot but
there is someone in the room that is not
6 foot. Those two statements contradict
each other the same way that that one
there contradicts each other. So using
that same logic we can derive a
contradiction from the Quran.
You know I could do this in interpretive
dance as well if you want. Like we can
make a fine that's fine. I definitely
How you guys do these chats every week?
I I'm live every Monday, Wednesday, and
and Friday usually, but
I'm going to be I'm I'm out of town
right now. So, this is next week. Next
week, I'll be back on schedule. Monday,
Wednesday, Friday. Bro,
are you in San Diego?
I I'm not in San Diego, but I'm I'm on
Cali Cali time.
Okay. All right. I'm guessing you guys
are going to move on. Can I Can I Before
you guys move on, can I ask like two
questions?
Sure. Sure, man. You You earned it, man.
You was polite. you've been respectful.
Hey, round of applause.
Thank you. Um, all right. I don't mean
to get political, right?
That question. Can I Can I just ask that
question?
All right. Go on.
A political question.
Yeah.
You say it's political, but I just feel
like it's human rights.
And there we go. We do theology, man.
No, no, no, no, no. I just It has
nothing I know it has nothing to do with
religion. I I just want to see where
Christians stand on it. And I'm not
asking you to give me my answer. I just
want to know. All right, go ahead.
With the marts and the innocence, bro.
Yeah, I'm not gonna lie to you. As with
I can ask.
Are you asking about Palestine?
Yeah. No, I was going to give you. Can I
just ask? If you don't have to answer,
you say I don't want to answer.
Go ahead.
So, obviously, it's not just Muslims
getting killed, right? It's Christians.
It's Catholics.
What's the percentage of Christians, you
think?
Who cares? No, I
I think it's I don't think it's very
high, right? I don't think it's very
high at all.
No, my brothers and sisters in the
Orthodox church predominantly as well, I
love them. I pray for them. I hope
they're well. I hope all the people who
are disaffected by this conflict are
well find peace in the Lord. Yeah.
And I hope that those who don't have
peace in the Lord find it.
Amen.
I want to be Christian there. I'm not
I just wanted to know. I just wanted to
know cuz I feel like I it's just opinion
of mine. I just feel like they're not
standing up enough. You know what I'm
saying? Like your channels cuz you guys
have channels.
Yeah. Well, we're not politicians with
No, that's what I said. That's what I
was saying. said, you know,
and we've already come out theologically
saying that everyone there should like
seek solidarity in Christian
organizations.
Yeah.
Pushing it at the beginning of your
video, at the end of video, you know, it
makes it a little more hurt.
So, here's what it's not my priority.
It's not our number one, it's not our
priority. Number two, what we would push
is for every single one in any of the
regions in the Middle East to become
Christian,
which is what we always do all the time.
And remember, like you're not not about
religion right now, just about
stable. Go on. I was going to ask him.
So, like, are you upset that Muslim
YouTubers don't post about Christians
being killed in Nigeria?
No. No. No. Yeah. No. Yeah. I'm upset
about the Congo, too. Congo.
Can I ask you a question? Should they be
doing more? Cuz as a Nigerian, I
couldn't go to the north of Nigeria
because my family would have not existed
anymore. Okay.
Should Muslim YouTubers have done more
to promote the slaughter of my people in
Nigeria? Should they have done more?
Oh, yeah.
And it's still going on. Okay. So the
very Okay, fine. So we need to clean up
our house and we will help you clean up
your house as well.
Yeah. Yeah.
Is that okay?
No, no, no. My point is not saying stand
up for the Muslims. I'm saying stand up.
No, that's not what I'm saying at all.
That's not what I'm saying at all. I'm
saying that the oppressive regimes and
systems that are across the world are
sectioned off politically
in which we interact with them. We show
solidarity to everyone suffering in the
world. It's not particularly a case
right now. I'm helping my people in my
home country because it's my home
country. You understand? Of which I
understand every single Palestinian that
has relatives in Gaza needing to support
them because of course everything's
getting copyed. I understand that.
Yeah. My best friend's aunt passed away
in Palestine only a couple months ago
from lack of healthcare. Believe me, I
love them. My heart goes out to them and
the Lord like I'm saying give them rest
and peace and blessings.
Amen. Of course.
All right. All right guys, we got to
move on.
But hey, Muhammad.
Yeah.
All right. We're live. We're live. You
know, I'm live weekly Monday, Wednesday,
Friday. You can pop up anytime, man.
You've proven that you're respectful.
You can have discussion. So, I like
that, man.
We need more people like you, dude.
Honestly, because a lot of people come
here to come back instead of
I'm not going to lie, before like you
had those YouTube videos, I would go off
in the comments just just to get put on.
When I get put on, I would have been
nice.
But I'm not gonna lie. I used to do that
just to get the attention. But
you shout you, bro.
But but now I know I won't do it. But
yeah, for sure I'll be looking.
Good. All right, take care of yourself.